Tim spur away from Chango it's called
hustle a column oriented distributed
event database so Tim spurway is a
software engineer who heads up
large-scale data team at Chango he's the
creator of Hustle the column oriented
embarrassingly distributed relational
event database which was open sourced in
March 04 so let's welcome Tim
hi there
does this work good
um yeah uh there was an announcement uh
Tomorrow People are supposed to go to
building 18 for registration that's
where everything's happening tomorrow so
they wanted us to to tell you that
um
we're going to talk about hustle today
and a couple of other projects that it
is heavily dependent on Disco and lmdb
um
what hustle is is uh is a database it's
a relational database it's meant for a
large scale
data and
um it's open source so we just open
source hustle
um on March 1st this year so it's
currently at 0.22 so it's pretty early
but we're using it uh at Chango we're an
ad tech company so we do you know
billions of Records a day with it and uh
it's working out pretty good uh it's a
column oriented
pipelined database so it's meant for
large data sets and the queries are
pretty quick
um
it's right optimized so we've got and
I'll go into a little bit more detail
later on we use what's called uh
distributed insert where we do all the
heavy lifting of indexing and column uh
you know laying things out in columns
in a distributed Manner and then push
into a distributed file system
uh it's distributed it leverages uh
discos mapreduce
um recently in disco disco
introduced pipelines so instead of just
a simple map reduce phases like you'd
have in Hadoop you can have
a lot more uh complicated or
sophisticated pipelined execution
ddfs is where we store this is disco's
distributed file system and that's where
data is replicated and stored
um it's fast we're using lmdb as the
base storage system
for our column oriented data
lmdb is uh from the open ldap project
and it is it's a slick little uh b-plus
tree implementation it blows the doors
off anything else out there
in my opinion
it's a relational database so you can do
joins and all of these things that we're
that we're used to from the relational
world it's actually optimized to join
across High cardinality Keys like sites
or cookie IDs and so on
um so it's it's it's a relational
database
but it's really
it's it's key feature is the query
language is not SQL so if you will it's
a relational nosql database
uh we leverage a lot of the operator
overloading and stuff in in Python to
give you the feel of a SQL like language
um but it's really just python there's a
number of advantages this gives us it
gives us extensibility gives us
efficiency because we don't have to
interpret SQL
we can just execute python
um
also I mean this combined with disco
which is a really low latency uh
mapreduce framework allows us to get
really good query execution
we do a lot of compression in the in the
database when you insert data we use a
lot of different uh
techniques for squishing the data down
and then we have also a command line
interface which we'll get into uh
quite a bit later
all right
so column orientation
um
for those of you not uh familiar with
column oriented databases most
relational style databases are row
oriented that is you store rows of data
together
which is great for small data sets but
for large data sets where you're
aggregating over a over a set of columns
a few columns column oriented is better
because you store all of the data for a
column together and then when you want
to do an aggregation operation over that
column or just select that column you
only have to go to one place so if you
have to sum up a column which is a very
common operation you just have you have
one you know burst through memory
summing stuff up so you get really uh
fast aggregations in it very efficient
it also has very good compression
characteristics and we'll take a look at
that in a in a while uh hustle uses
bitmap indexes
so uh column more in a databases really
go well hand in hand with bitmap indexes
I'll explain what these are too in the
next slide
um
this is a little this is the hustle DSL
an example so this is uh an example of
creating a table
all right so I mean it looks like ddl
from the SQL world but it's python
you'll notice some of the types like
tree
uh you know
we have a whole bunch of different uh
sizes of ins and so on there's indexes
so you specify whether you're indexing a
column we have types like bit
which actually are stored in a single
bet in a bitmap index so a lot of the
types are different than a traditional
database but it's for compressibility
and efficiency
all right
so I'm going to talk a little bit about
the layout of Hustle we'll get to actual
doing some coding and stuff and uh into
the tutorial part but I just wanted to
give you some background on how hustle's
laid out and how it works
so when you insert data into hustle what
you're doing is you're creating a what
we call a marble file which is a memory
mapped b-plus tree that contains all the
columns for a given partition for a
given table
so here I've got this let's say this is
a file and I've just inserted a bunch of
data into this table I've got three
columns and some metadata
um
so all of the data is column oriented
it's not it's you have a row ID and then
you have the value so this the column is
named amount it's got a site ID an ad ID
key value ordered key value
so you've got a row ID and the value
now you can imagine if I want to
aggregate over this amount I would be
able to very quickly get a hold of this
uh uh you know table and aggregate all
those so if I was doing a sum or an
average over amount I'd be able to very
quickly aggregate there
um
so this is how data is stored how about
indexes
oh one one point I wanted to point out
here for compression is if uh when you
have rows if adjacent rows have the same
value you can just skip them so that's a
form of compression actually right so if
here the first 21 rows of my site ID
have the value cnn.com
so we just put record this one and the
values that change so you can get really
high compression on on low cardinality
values which happens often
okay so this is where I've indexed my
site ID and my ad ID we create another
two key value pairs for this column for
these columns
and it's inverted so you have the key is
the value from the from the other uh
table
and the value is a bitmap index and what
a bitmap is simply a set of bits that is
the same width as the number of rows
so now when you do ands and or
operations or joins you can do bitwise
operations on them
we use a um a really fast
bitmap index implementation the Ewa Bool
library
and it compresses so it does run length
compression and so on as well so these
are very efficient and very fast bitmaps
um so that's how the indexing works so
indexes basically make your where
Clauses fast this is how we do where
clauses
okay so let's insert some data into
Hustle
I talked about this before uh inserts
are distributed
one of the problems with traditional
relational technology even data
warehouses is that you do an insert
statement and all the indexing that
happens and all of the heavy lifting of
organizing indexes you know inserting
the data into the database happens on
the server if it's a distributed
database it happens on that cluster so
all of those machine Cycles to compress
and create the indexes are operations
that are going to be robbing from your
query performance
so what we do instead is we do all the
heavy lifting remotely so say you had a
thousand machines that are creating
event logs those thousand machines could
be creating marble files locally which
are fully indexed Standalone
databases that which are then pushed
into a distributed file system queries
then have free run of the cluster and
there is zero expense for indexing and
so on on the cluster so that's why we
call it distributed insert and it scales
really well for Big Data
so your first step create your
Standalone marble this is expensive
column oriented databases typically are
very expensive to do insert operations
so we distribute it
push your marble into distributed file
system
that's cheap that's just a that's a
blasting bits over your wire
and that's cluster local
so what do I got here uh one insert can
create and push any number of
partitioned marbles so the database also
has this concept of partitions which
allows you usually you partition on date
or year or some column that allows you
to split your data up so this allows you
to
when you're inserting one file you could
it could actually create a number of
marbles one for each partition
we support a number of
file formats for your insert
this is growing we're looking at the
scientific stuff like H5 and and a lot
of other uh
uh you know file formats
um the one thing about this distributed
insert is you can't really insert one
row at a time you have to insert uh you
have to be aware of how big the objects
that you're pushing into your
distributed file system are because they
become a unit of mapreduce
you don't want to have millions of them
you want to you want to size them
properly so the one downside of this is
that you need to pay careful attention
to your ETL
typically like what we do with our big
data sets that we're pushing in is you
know take 20 minutes worth of data from
a single server or five minutes or an
hour and
uh and then that way we can control the
size and how complex basically you're
controlling your query time later on too
here's an example of of inserting some
python some data into this table called
impressions
okay uh I mean I've talked about this
disco and discos distributed file system
uh disco is
who here is familiar with mapreduce by
the way like uh okay it's a lot of
people
um
disco is unlike uh
uh hadoops hdfs in a few ways one of the
one of those ways is that it's tag based
uh instead of directory based
which means that you have a many many
relationship between tags which is how
you access your data and blobs which is
the actual data itself
now the cool thing about disco is that
it allows you to have metadata on your
tags so what we did was we leveraged
that to store all the metadata about our
table we don't need to have like a
separate database somewhere tracking all
our metadata we just put all of the
column type information and so on about
our our
tables in these tag attributes
also
we use the tag names to store our
partitions so a table uh
you know this is a tag in Disco so by
convention we use these colons to
separate chunks of the tag everything
starts with hustle in the distributed
database the table name is Impressions
and then this is the partition
if I did a ddfs LS or a ddfs blobs to
find out what this was connected to I
would find these uh URLs to where the
actual data is
so we're leveraging all discos features
to store our metadata and to do our
partitioning so now when I execute
Aquarian hustle and I say where date
equals or is greater than August you
know 17th it'll be smart enough to just
pick those tags for that partition
making my query faster because they'll
be looking at less data
all right
uh so how do you query this thing right
um well it's python DSL
we've overloaded we've taken some
liberties with the DSL idea and
overloaded some operators and what might
seem like a strange way but it works
pretty well
um
you can do aggregating
you know we have these uh this and a lot
more aggregation functions
um you can do efficient joins and it's
designed to do uh joins across High
cardinality uh
keys
you can do order limit descending
distinct one of the things that we
really like Target for for our uh use
case is our data science team
they like to do exploratory work so we
really uh
leverage this idea of nesting queries
that is you do a query you assign it to
a variable it's stored the result is
going to be stored back into the Disco
distributed file system and it can be
used as the input for another query so
queries can be nested the results can be
saved as temporary tables if you will
and then
exactly so we don't have group by we
don't have from
SQL doesn't really have group by either
it has it but you know it gives you an
error if you don't do it so do it
properly so we just do it like this
and that covers off 100 of the use cases
so there is some differences about about
this this select statement there's no
from Clause there's just a where Clause
the where Clause takes a list or in this
case a tuple of tables
or it just takes one one what's this one
yeah
so it takes a list so this is a tuple uh
this is the first one
this is the second one
right
um
you can join
you can do order by all of these are
quite uh quite powerful here you see
we're joining on site ID you could
specify a column there you can specify
the name of the column here or the index
into the select statement or a list and
we'll see a lot more queries when we get
into the Hands-On part
yep
where true how do you specify that how
do you specify the table if you're
pulling the so we're specifying the
table in the where Clause so this
expression has to be only on the imps
table
this expression has to be on the pitch
if you're not doing any filtering then
how do you specify oh you can just say
imps you could put a table name in here
okay
so
you can also have multiple tables sorry
in your where Clause without a join if
you want
um if it's only one table uh what are
you joining to or are you joining The
Columns you don't need a you don't need
to have uh join this is just an example
there's a join in this query
there's two tables so this is the
Impressions table and this is the pixel
table okay
because this is a tuple here
I think it is
yeah yeah
so
it's a little bit
hard to get used to from SQL it breaks
your brain a bit but it actually I think
it makes more sense than SQL
okay so uh how are how are queries
executed
um now I talked about the Disco project
The Godfather of the Disco project is
here Ville
and it's been around for quite some time
it's uh
it's a very lightweight uh mapreduce
framework but in the latest uh revision
of the software it's actually gone much
Beyond mapreduce
uh it's introduced the concept of
pipelines which gives us a generalized
uh distributed execution engine
hustle takes full advantage of these
pipelines when you execute a query you
can have anywhere between one stage
pipeline to a seven stage pipeline
depending on the complexity of your
query and how the query Optimizer wants
to combine or separate your stages what
I tried to do here was some color coding
for like this is an aggregate stage so
you you know mapreduce is mapreduce
uh maybe a combine or sword in the
middle but it's mapreduce that's what
it's called but uh you know a hustle
query in this case has five separate
distinct stages
with different fan in semantics and
grouping semantics
um and sorting different ways on on the
different uh sorting or merging
depending on the stage
um so we're trying to map up the uh you
know all the different uh
stages on this slide
all right
make sense
okay so here's my shout out page we're
going to get into uh taking a look at
some queries and I'm going to get you
guys to log in
um
but I do want to shout out to the Disco
project first of all you know this is
this is an amazing project if you guys
are using uh Hadoop you should
you should take a look at disco at least
just take a look at it it's it's really
it's really a good environment we've
scaled it up to I mean we've got
uh 100 100 nodes ish I know that Nokia
had a bigger cluster than that but it's
petabyte kind of scale uh
we don't have any problems with it we've
become a major maintainer of this
project ourselves
it's written in erlang and python
super lightweight and really fast
lmdb from the open ldap project Howard
Chu is an amazing uh
amazing b-plus tree implementation
uh the ewabulary this is our bitmap
index
we use lz4 compression as well it's
another option for compressing data and
alter Json we do a lot of Json
processing and this is very fast
okay
so
we have a hip chat room set up if you
want to like message each other we got a
whole row of guys here that can come
around and help you with queries and
stuff
um we what we want you to do is SSH into
our AWS disco cluster we've set up a
cluster for running queries and stuff
if you want to install hustle and disco
and everything on your own laptops we
got guys that can help you do that
um but if you just want to play around
with the CLI and do some queries and
stuff I've got some exercises here and
we can walk through it and I want it to
be very back and forth uh I mean if you
have questions just shout them out and
uh we can go through it
this is the directions you can just SSH
into
this machine
at the prompt you can type hustle and
I'll kind of walk you through what
you're going to see
this is useful for writing queries the
hustle documentation
because you probably don't know all of
the syntax and whatnot uh but we'll
figure it out
so when you type hustle this is what you
get it's actually just a python repo
that we've kind of
uh
uh jigged up a bit
what it should tell you is all of your
tables hustle tables that are available
some commands to get you started a list
of commands you can list your tables you
can exit
uh if you do the commands you'll be able
to see all the other commands and stuff
that we can do
uh if I want to switch
okay
so what I'm gonna do
can we all read this
okay I will make it bigger then
tell me when that's good
more
that's good
all right
so
um let's go ahead and say commands
so this is like just a little bit of
help this is python though I mean
anything that you can do in Python you
can do in here
we've added auto complete capabilities
so if you type in a table name say
observations which is one of my tables
absurd and I hit Tab It Auto completes
and then if I put a dot to dereference
the column
it gives me all the columns and allows
me to go in and say oh I meant uh date
so it'll auto complete so that's that's
kind of nice it also Auto completes your
commands so select
um
let's do uh well let's take a look at
the schema
of our stations oh I forgot to tell you
what the data is
um so do you know the million song
database
it's like there's a million songs
literally exactly one million songs
and we also so we've got that and we
also have
um and there's a couple tables there we
also have all the weather data weather
observations from across the world from
1929 to 2009 every single day every
single station uh it's about so we're
talking like 150 million records
you know in the ad Tech business that
we're in that's about 50 seconds of data
so I mean
it's uh it's big-ish data but I don't
know if it's it's it's it's a good set
to mess around with but
um the hardware we're running on is AWS
mystery Hardware
um we've got a 10 node
uh disco cluster
um and so what we're going to do is
we're going to go through a couple of
exercises to just get used to the data
so let's take a look at the stations so
we can say schema stations which we just
did oh by the way there's also a history
function
uh this is I'm just hitting the arrow
keys here so if you want to get back to
your query
you can just use the arrow key in the
CLI
um so the stations is weather stations
so we've got this guy here Latin long
what we did was we just combined Latin
long got rid of the decimal point so it
gives you kind of a square if you
compare it to other stations it'll give
you a square of about I don't know 30
miles by 30 miles it's a full degree
um there's call codes so KSFO is is San
Francisco's airport
um there's lat long there's region
country uh name and so on
so we could say select
um
uh stations
dot name
where
stations
dot call code
equals
KSFO
so it's got two of them in there that's
the data set has two of them now a
couple things about this
uh this equals operator what happened
there if this is just python shouldn't
this evaluate to true or false or
something well it doesn't it evaluates
to an expression that is pushed out into
and evaluated on every single marble
during the query execution so we've
overloaded this operator
to give us a deferred kind of Lambda
expression that will get executed during
the query
so where where is that clear result is
that in memory now where's the query
result right now is it in memory or on
Disco file system okay so on uh
it's it's
kind of in memory uh the idea when
you're in the CLI we have uh an option
called dump
so what I can do here is I could say
and dump is equal to True only in the
CLI so what it's trying to do is just
allow you to dump out all the results to
standard out but normally like when
you're programming dump will be false
and a select statement will actually
return a table object that can be
plugged into other queries or iterated
over and so on so if I wanted to check
this out I'll say dump equals false
and I'll assign this to
SFO let's say
so it runs
then I can say
for a name in SFO
print SFO
oops
thank you
sorry
oh
oh it already yeah it was a generator
it's been
consumed
so it returns a tuple set which will
have all of your columns
um
okay
that's the other thing is we made it
exceedingly easy to interface with this
thing in regular python a table if I
want to do the same thing so all my
tables remember I'll clean the screen
here tables
if I want to go over let's go over well
the stations this is our smallest table
so I can just say for
station top and stations
print
station top
so
you know you can interact with your data
just using regular python stuff or you
can select it and that returns a table
that you can interact with just using
regular python stuff
if I do a select statement with two
columns how does it determine in what
order the columns are returned in the
result set that's the order that you
typed them in
thanks
okay so let's go to uh the first
question
in our I'm going to not do this full
screen anymore
we're going to do a question and if you
guys are all logged in did everyone get
logged in was there any problems
sure
oh yeah you can go to hipchat or
it's drteeth million.chango.com
and the password is pi data with big p
Big D 2014.
well it not lazy but deferred so what
you can say is uh you know if you know
the query is going to take 20 minutes
uh what you can say is is defer the
query and it'll return a future object
to you that you can then use in other
queries and you know when when it needs
to when it's ready you know it'll come
back so you can start a whole bunch of
queries and then use the values you can
wait for it there's a whole protocol I'm
not going to get into that in this talk
but uh unless we have time but it's it's
pretty cool we we added that recently
yeah sorry this is the command that
you're going to type once you get in
sorry
I I tricked him and him with that one so
it must be uh
it's me not uh
okay here's our exercise
uh I'll put this maybe I will put this
up in full screen here
okay get the total number of days of
rain in 2009 for all weather stations
so I don't want you to join against any
tables right now just for the
observations uh table we just need the
station IDs
uh in California
so basically this is an aggregating
query you're going to group by
well you're not going to group by you're
going to select the station ID and
um the count
where there is rain that day
so if you use the schema command to go
and take a look at the observations you
should find a hint
called the rain column
for whether there is a rain or not it's
a bit it means that it's either zero or
one
you can sum it up if you want but if you
put it in a where Clause it'll be a lot
more
uh it'll be a lot faster because it
won't have it'll be able to narrow down
to where the rain is true rather than
doing a table scan over that partition
okay so there's some gotchas
uh
I talked about this already this is the
way that you look at the schema of a of
a table
uh selects I didn't talk about this you
can't use the and pythons and is not
overrideable because of its short
circuit function so this is why we had
to use a bit wise and to specify an and
remember the the equal equal is just a
Lambda that gets executed in or
mapreduce same with the and so we can't
use Python's A and D operator right
uh now that introduces this because the
Precedence of this is higher than this
you need to parenthesize everything in a
where clause
sorry but
as the best we could do
it's still worth it because this is a
lot more terse and useful than the
equivalent parenthesize functional kind
of expression
um so when you're doing you're going to
have to use an and in this situation
make sure you wrap
the parenthesis around your expressions
aggregating functions all start with an
H underscore because there's stuff
called sum and count already in Python
and I don't wanna I don't want to you
know mess with it
uh bit columns or one bit integers and
not bools
although you can compare them to true
and false it'll cast it but don't
anybody need any help or anybody got an
answer
okay
you got an answer
okay so I'm going to go to the next uh
I'm going to give you the answer in the
interest of time we can have a jam if at
the end if we uh
right okay oh did I go too far
okay so I'm not supposed to hit the red
but I will
okay so we're going to select
observations dot station ID
comma H underscore count comma where
observations.rain equals one and
observations at year equals 2009 and
observations our region equals CA
somebody want to test that that actually
works
here I can't
okay first thing I'm going to do
remember this is python I'm going to say
OBS equals observations because that's
pretty
um
so OBS it's just a table it's a table
object I'm going to say I select
OBS Dot
what was it
station ID comma H count
comma where
um
OBS Dot
year
equals 2009.
and
OBS dot reign
equals one
ABS Dot
region
oh shoot okay
yeah actually it's in the station sorry
yeah
okay so you can do you can do this query
you can't do the station you can't do
the region until you join with the next
table so I did get ahead of myself there
so we can do this query
if you okay
so this gives me a bunch of station IDs
so these are all the station IDs across
the world
in order to actually answer the question
in fact it was a trick question uh
to answer the question properly would
have would have taken a join which we're
going to do next
okay so this actually remember the
observations is 110
or 120 million so data points this had
to visit an awful lot of them uh I mean
it was able to narrow it down because
our petition is this guy so that out of
50 years it probably divided the amount
of data had to be visited into 50 and
then this is represented as a bitmap
index so assuming that there's fewer
days where it rains in California than
not and this year I know that's the case
then this would have narrowed the amount
of data down a lot more that our
mapreduce job would have had to uh you
know consider
so
yeah okay not a method it's a functional
I'm confused about is it a function ID
or what it's okay aggregating function
what it returns is a an aggregation
object
that gets executed during mapreduce so
if you if you think about mapreduce it's
what happens during reduce so you could
have H sum of a column
or age average or min max whatever or H
count which just counts uh you know it's
a reduced function that just like select
count of something in SQL
it's just generating something else is
getting executed yeah so it gets
executed uh an incrementer gets executed
during a reduce or an aggregation phase
uh during the query and the reason it's
got parameters is because you could do
some different things with it versus
just like no it's a function
it this function returns an aggregation
object so it's to be consistent with all
the other rather than just putting
object in there yeah you could actually
create an aggregator object it's just
another python object and create your
own and that's actually how you do how
this is extensible right because you can
create your own aggregation objects like
like we've done uh cardinality
estimation over hlls and uh and uh
minhash so you can do you know you can
it's extensible unlike you know a SQL
interpreter would be
okay so let's go to our next question
oh that's cool
um
okay now let's join this query against
the stations table to select the
station's name and stations lat long
columns
with the counter rain days so basically
we're going to hit the up arrow on this
query and join
our stations table
and select
you know in our projection here the
station's name and station lat long
and you may as well add in where the
stations.region equals California
because this should be stations.region
um
okay how do you do joins we kind of saw
it earlier on uh you have to specify all
your tables and your where Clause they
can be expressions like this or they can
just be in the name of the table the
table object could be a nested query as
well
and then you say what column you want to
join on if the column is the same name
in both tables you can just put the
string
of the table name otherwise you have to
specify a tuple with two table dot
column expressions
so that
easier to show you than to do it or to
talk about it
okay
so I'm going to clear up my screen here
I'm going to go back to my other query
and I'm just going to hack it so I'm
saying
obs.stationid I also want to select
station
Dot and I forgot the name of the columns
that's not going to help me
makes a liar out of me oh it's because
it's station Stations
so what did I want I wanted lat long
right
and I wanted
um
the name
and I wanted a where Clause I'm gonna
so now my wear actually has to become
a two element I use tuples but you could
use an array if you want maybe using an
array would make it more clear what I'm
doing here
so because we're doing a join we've
we've specified stations in the
projection like which columns I want
so we have to specify it in the where
Clause so that we know what we want to
do here
so I'm going to add another element to
this array and I'm going to say whereas
stations
Dot
region
equals
California
and I can finish off my array
and then I have to say join
on station ID
right
so you guys see what I'm doing here
uh
specified
an array of two table expressions
so it knows what tables that it's going
to work on
and we specify to join on the column
that exists in both tables
they're not the same name
so the question was what if I've got
different names in the two tables well
I'll show you the equivalent drawing to
take care of that case I would say
here's the
stations Dot
station ID comma
OBS Dot
station ID is the equivalent
so this case can be shortened to just
quote station ID because it's uh
but this will work fine and this is how
you do it if they're different
okay let's see this execute
okay so what did we get here
um these are all the California
weather stations that reported more than
one day of rain in 2009.
I was expecting maybe a bigger list
I don't know
we did just load the data
today
we were expecting like maybe 10 people
for the so we had a small cluster AWS
cluster of three machines and we're
no that's not going to do so we wiped it
brought up 10 or 12 nodes and reloaded
all the data anyway so you get the idea
here's your station ID
your name your count
all right so that was a question and
here's the answer
ah see
it's a bug that's actually
stations
okay so the next thing we're going to do
here uh is extender query
to select only the top 10 rainfall
locations so
um the way you do this is you use a
limit you use a descending equals true
and you do an order by the order by is
really flexible you can specify a zero
based index
like zero one two so in this case we
want to order by this I don't want to
order by H count I want to order by the
second
uh you know column in the result
um you can order by the column name if
it's Unique if it's uh can be figured
out from a string if you need to specify
specifically that it's you know a column
like if you got a name from both two
different tables like it wouldn't be
able to resolve it if you just said name
so you'd have to specify the actual name
also you can introduce there's a way of
introducing aliases and columns to name
them something uh that you want to do
yourself
and that's the column object has a DOT
named we won't get into it but it's
there in the documentation if you want
to mess around with it
so let's go and do this query
I hope you guys are getting the idea of
how where this where this is going
um
uh
all right
um so let's clear our screen
I'm going to make this a little bit
nicer just join on
station
ID
we're going to say
order by
equals
and I I'm just going to go I want to
order by the H count so that 0 1 2 3
that's the third projected column so I
can say order by three
limit
equals 10.
and I need it in reverse order
so that's how you do that
Santa Rosa is that a rainy place
I don't know
if you say so I don't know
all right
um
so we got a whole bunch other we got the
million song
database as well
so I mean if you want we can figure out
you know in this rainy
you know was there any albums released
you know in that town that's so rainy
for example
um so let's take a look at our song
stuff so tables
there's a million song database I can
prove it too so if I do a select
um on songs
oh wait I'm going to do H count
comma songs
oh wait sorry where songs
okay here's a case where I'm just using
the table name in the where clause
um
it's called a million song database for
a reason it's not around a million I
don't know how they called it I don't
know
um so yeah let's let's take one of the
things in the uh okay so we have tables
uh we have songs and we have artists
so look at let's look at the schema
of songs
what do we got here
we got an artist ID that sounds like a
join we got decade we got the release
um
and duration that's something we could
aggregate on probably
um and the name so how about let's look
at the schema
of artists
huh it's got lat long okay well that's
the same as my lat long for my weather
station query so I could probably join
against
figure out you know what artists live in
Santa Rosa
I haven't done this query before there
may not be any but given the fact that
you know certain types of music likes
precipitation
it's possible
oh good question
so the star
right there
uh is just an indication in the schema
printout that that column is the
partition column
so you know that this data is
partitioned by by decade
um
so what am I going to do I'm going to
look for
um songs
oh and there's another star that you can
do you can say star star of a table name
this is like saying star and SQL
except you got to do star star
it's python right so this is going to
unpack all of the columns in that table
the star operator in Python unpacks
arrays or tuples and star songs as a
function that returns all the columns in
a in a table here
maybe I should do this in two steps if I
say star songs
I get uh
an array
of column objects
this is python right so if I say uh
select
star star songs
that array gets unpacked and I get all
of the columns in the table
where uh
oh
I also want the artist name right oh
sorry songs comma artist
Dot
name
where
okay so now uh we're selecting all the
data from the songs and the artist's
name
and so we have to specify
you know the the where Clause I'm going
to say where songs
and
artists.lat long
equals you know that lat long for Santa
Rosa
duration
of the song
I think it's in seconds
there's a lot it's interesting there's a
lot of songs I was messing around with
there's like significant number of songs
under 10 seconds
yeah 240 million under
oh okay so 240 million seconds
you can do an average too yeah
there's there's a lot of long songs out
there
I think it's seconds I'm pretty sure
it's seconds
yeah well some recordings you know of
some things I don't know
yeah you can do uh H Min H Max so you
could find the minimum and maximum
duration song in the database
um
yeah have at her you know it's uh
uh okay so I'm selecting star songs uh
the name of the artist I'm gonna oh I
gotta do a join
and I'm going to say
comma
join
artist ID
artist
ID
oh
really
or is it going to work at all
you are 100 correct
okay
so that's got to join against all
basically it's got to do a row
um
you know a
table scan of songs
and I don't think songs is even oh yeah
it's it's well it's got to do all of
them I mean you could uh you could
narrow it down by using uh the songs
ah partition or trying to you know to
make the query go faster you could
you know
pick a better where clause
so
so there is that's a lot of data how
about let's do it again and just select
uh
uh I don't know a couple of columns from
the song
all right
duration
oh here if I clear my screen
it will be much better one of the things
I haven't showed you uh is we can look
at our queries executing
um now we can all hit this interface
here but I'd uh I'd appreciate it if all
of us didn't hit the interface at the
same time
um because uh
uh just
it's a
so this is actually all of our queries
executing these are the mapreduce jobs
these are the nodes that get the yellow
is the lighting up of the uh of the
processors so we have uh you know eight
processes per node that can execute uh
these queries
you know processing moves to the data in
mapreduce in general and you know and
disco's no exception it you know you can
look at an individual query here
um
you know all the users here are going to
be doctor teeth because all of us are Dr
Teeth obviously
um
but you know if you had your own user ID
and so on like we would be able to uh to
do that
um you can see how long the query is
taking
um you know total execution time if
you're debugging stuff you can see uh
you know messages in the console here
let's look for something that has
multiple stages if you look here you can
see
um this is the stages so this is a
really I can tell whoever typed in this
query is a simple simple one stage so
that's just a where clause
but if there's probably one not too far
down here that has a join
yeah so this one has three stages
let's find one with a join
well there's one with a join
okay
so
you can see how this thing is depending
on the sophistication of the query
you're going to get a pipelined
mapreduce job that is going to change in
complexity that meets the
and that dynamically happens right it
figures out when it schedules a job one
of the things if you compare the
execution of this stuff to say Hadoop
um you can see the low latency of hus of
uh disco
very simple jobs
are done in less than a second the you
don't have to package up a jar file and
put it in some cash somewhere to be
pulled out and executed so
disco is really good for fast small
stuff when you when you dispatch a
mapreduce job everything that you need
for that job like if you just change
code it gets packaged up with the job
pack and sent out right then so the code
gets pickled it's a dynamic language
and so you can you can very quickly
develop things it's actually a
completely different use case than say
something like Hadoop that requires a
lot more infrastructure around it to to
execute if you want to compare hustle I
mean there's Impala in the Hadoop world
there's Hive obviously
um there's Dremel over at Google
but hustle really answers even a
different use case than those systems
all of those systems use you know
leverage a really big cloud they're
column oriented but they do Full Table
scans right they they you know Mash all
the data together you know when you type
Aquarius SQL in at you know bigquery
prompt it's going to table scan
everything and it's got enough
processors that it can do it efficiently
but what hustle tries to do is it gives
you that where Clause it has the B plus
tree marbles that it can go in and just
select the data that you need and so
this is really a lot better for
analytical workloads where you're uh you
know winnowing your data down to a
manageable set saving it you know as
temporary tables in those Nest equals
true kind of uh ideas that we were
talking about and you know doing
experimentation with your with your data
and your queries
okay so that's a tour of that
uh
so Santa Rosa Julie London
uh diesel boy groundation
groundation that's a great name
um okay so I mentioned this uh
nestability and so on of uh data so
you know uh for any query that you give
you can say
you can assign a value right so you can
say you know temp tab
okay so there's dump equals false
but with dump equals false it just gives
you a list of tuples it gives you the
results as a list of tuples but if you
say Nest equals true
in your pro I think that's good enough
so it'll run the query again
and it it will save that data in Hustle
native format so the output of the job
instead of being a list a distributed
list of tuples that are the tuples in
that query it's actually going to create
um queryable
uh
a a real first class table that we can
go and drill down into well there's an
error okay
worker is behaving badly
oh I've got some uh debugging code in
here
that's not good
that's embarrassing yeah I know exactly
what happened here but uh okay so yeah I
was debugging something
I don't want to fix it
I could but I'm not going to
okay so uh
uh
so the idea here is you say Nest equals
true and the output gets put into a set
of uh marbles that can be
you know so my next query was going to
say select uh distinct artist or temptab
dot name from uh temp tab or where temp
Tab and that would have given me all the
unique uh you know
um yeah probably
um
yeah you can
because
you know you could put another select
statement inside of the where cloth
because it's just python right
so you can that's why it's called Nest
equals true
that nested one has to be told hey I
don't want a simple Tuple uh response I
want an actual marble response so that I
can go and Nest so this is used for if
you've got really big data sets like
some of these queries it's fast but it's
not like it's not super fast some of
them can take 10 20 minutes
to actually give
more meaningful yeah so by default the
question was can you name things other
than what they're they're called
um and yeah you can so what you can do
uh any column
can be
so you can rename anything you want
so it's just you know it really is just
a python object right and you can you
can say I want to name this thing that
and the column when it comes back
unless there's a bug in this too
or debug code
um you'll we'll see the results we'll
come back and the column will be named
seconds and that column in the nest
equals true case will be second so you
do a select you know based on the second
uh yeah it's just gonna dump it out I
can't do the nest because I put my
debugging code is still in there so I
got rid of the debugging or the nest
equals true
um
so we're table scanning on this you can
always go and take a look at you know
your query
like it's progress
so I'm doing a restrict select first
let's finish that phase
of going on to a join in the join phase
right now
what did it die
foreign
yeah
and so let's go up to the oh I didn't
call it that
okay so I'm a liar
I know in the object like in the table
that it creates it will create it with
seconds so if you do then s equals true
you can
that definitely works
as I said it's a early version of uh so
there's there's a couple of rough edges
but I think it just adds to the charm
um
okay
uh any other questions
yeah so the question was can can you
write your own functions in the where
clause
or your own aggregating functions right
um yeah you can uh this is I mean it's
open source software
um you wouldn't even have to deploy in
most cases you wouldn't even have to
deploy new code to the uh to the cluster
you could add now you'd have to go in
and take a look at the hustle code it's
very well commented by the way
seriously it is and um and you have to
you know you have to fall it's a
framework uh uh and but there is a way
to extend it you can create uh there's
column objects there's
um table objects there's aggregation
objects which are the aggregating
functions there's expert objects which
are the expressions
um
and the ands just create it'll create a
tree like an AST tree for the
expressions
um you have to take care of whether it's
a partition or going to be executed
during mapreduce so there's there's a
you know but it's laid out and it's
totally extensible that was one of the
reasons that we didn't want to go with
yet another SQL based uh system because
we know that we've got machine learning
plugins that we want to write that are
going to be you know added to this
cardinality estimation plugins that
we've already started on hustle right
now comes with basic cardinality
estimation based on hll
uh and Min hash
um so we wanted to build an extensible
query platform that we could you know
some of uh of the blaze stuff for
example you can see this uh you know as
a front end or or uh integrating with
that set of software to do you know
vector and Matrix stuff
um so yeah we definitely want to play
nice with the with the python ecosystem
and you know
a lot of things you know SQL is great
everybody knows it there's a lot of
advantages to that but in a way it's a
really a closed book you know and the
types of systems that we're trying to
integrate you know often SQL is kind of
a dead end in terms of integration with
other stuff
so that's kind of a long answer for that
yep
so I got 318 questions but I'm just
going to ask one uh I didn't notice
anything about foreign keys in there and
I noticed you're manually specifying the
join every time
one thing that I found really useful I
had an arm that I wrote
10 years ago in Python was just that
you could you could specify once okay
the observations joins naturally with
the stations on on these keys and then
you could actually do some
pre-calculation
of those joints have you done any work
in that direction
um yeah so about foreign keys and
pre-computing I mean
we've thought about it but um at you
know if you add more data to your system
then you invalidate your
you know it's a distributed system so
it's we don't know in any Central Point
when data has been added so it's hard to
kind of pre-compute stuff
however that being said we've got super
fast sorting at the basis of
you know disco
so and that's really I mean it does
emerge join
um
now there's hash joins as well that we
could implement but they're a little bit
more complicated
and so far the joints for our use cases
which are high cardinality keys
it works really really well for for that
type of uh thing
it's a lot easier
to build a database system that's kind
of that's that's closed and on one
system you know so you know where
everything is with this it's it's
distributed it's shared nothing so we
have to do you know we have to do it uh
and take different approaches
good question
anyone else
valet
it's like under like real production
load occasionally use only use timeouts
or so occasionally you see timeouts or
or something like that so what's your
like preferred way of debugging jobs so
do you actually log into the node or
yeah the recommended way of doing that
so yeah I mean so the questions about
debugging debugging queries or debugging
Hustle
yeah
yeah it's it's it's early we've got uh
we're trying to catch as much as we can
up front so we have a query syntax
Checker that
um we go through and make sure that if
you've specified a join that there's you
know enough uh exactly two tables
um and I mean we try and do as much
syntax checking up front as we can
um but yeah you're right if uh it can be
difficult I mean what we do is dip down
into the the Disco level
and take a look at it one thing that you
can do that we've added to disco in the
recent uh release is the temporary
results from any stage are fetchable
from the command line so you can go in
if something's not working exactly the
way you think it should be working you
can go and look at your stages you know
if it was a restrict select into a
combiner into a join or however it's set
up you can pick the name of that stage
in the job ID and say well what was the
results from that stage and then you can
go and take a look at them and say oh I
see what's going on here like I've got
you know this key is wrong or something
like that
um
but as far yeah as far as hustle's
concerned we've got uh you know unit
tests but we've also got an extensive
integration test uh Suite that you know
it's pretty comprehensive and expects a
full installation of disco on your
machine and so on so
I'm just asking for uh I'll repeat it oh
sure just for nesting
um the queries when you have a nest
nested query how you actually would
technically set it up we know it's not
necessarily running properly but just
maybe an example for someone if they
were poking around okay so the questions
about nesting queries and this is a it's
really a killer feature of of uh hustle
it's really you take any query and you
say Nest equals true
and what that does normally if I didn't
I would just get I would get an iterator
back a generator
and when I iterate over it I'll get a
list of tuples
that has my result if I say Nest equals
true I get a table object back
that table is stored in a distributed
manner in
um Disco so that and it's a first class
table it's stored in the the temporary
space the data space so-called in Disco
but it can be executed you can execute
other queries on it and you simply just
say Nest equals true
and you assign it to a variable
and then that variable will contain a
table that can be selected on and used
in another select
I was wondering is there a way to add
constraints to the columns or
how does it deal with the yeah missing
data and channel joins so questions
about uh uh Missing data and constraints
when you do an insert into uh into
Hustle
you get to specify a decoder which is
the type you know J there's a Json
decoder there's a fixed CSV decoder
there's a fixed width decoder so that's
the first kind of constraint is the the
type of the data but you also get to
specify a function that allows you to
format it's a preprocessor so it gets
called for every line and it's up to you
to to format and do your ETL properly
but there's there's hooks for it it's
built into the system
how difficult would it be to map like
the columns to the d-type structure in
numpy because for example like getting
getting the iterator for I don't know 20
million euros
might be a little expensive if you
wanted to put it into into pandas or
something like that
um whereas if you know it's smaller
that's fine but
yeah so yeah integration with other
systems I don't know exactly uh that for
that particular example maybe somebody
else would be able to to answer it the
thing is that it's it is just Python and
the answer would be it's going to be the
same as any other python framework for
integrating large amounts of data it's
not going to make it
any easier but it's not going to make it
any more difficult either so the same
strategies that you would use for other
large pieces of data
but the good news is it's all python so
you don't gotta you know translate from
a different format or anything and
everything that you're dealing with in
Hustle is going to be a generator you
never like we're very conscious about
loading data into memory in All Phases
whether it's you know deep down in the
mapreduce stuff or how you deal with
results you're only ever dealing with
generators
another one in the back
um so I think someone touched on this
earlier but all of the queries you
showed are around pulling data but none
of them really
transformed the data does it have the
ability to do that
or aggregate some of them aggregated the
data too but
what if I want to take like the hash of
that string as output or something okay
um without using an extra stat yeah
we've got um now that is is pretty easy
uh if you're just dealing with one
column
but and our number one feature request
from our data science team is I want to
be able to do uh transformative
functions over multiple columns
so that's definitely on our on our
feature list and on our radar and we're
adding that kind of as as we speak
so yeah that's that's I mean you can do
some stuff right now but
um we're definitely working on on a
framework for that
anybody else
so
I know probably a lot of the data you
work with is string bass but in the
scientific community and a lot of test
data that I look at is mostly floats
yeah how how scalable is it to say I
want to load up you know 10 million
floats and just do different things with
them how do you pass that data into
like what what kernels are distributed
and running where's the data in memory
how does it get worked out
right now we don't support floating
Point
um
it's it's a it's a matter of uh uh lmdb
doesn't natively support floating Point
although it supports a comparison
uh function so we could fake it but I
want to I would rather work with uh
Howard and the lmdb team and get floats
added and make sure that the
implementation is really performant
rather than put something in there that
is going to have lackluster performance
because I know you guys are gonna you
know
you know really kick the hell out of it
right so
um that's that's definitely on our plan
as well and uh I mean we use floating
Point data as well but now we're just
rounding it up to integers kind of thing
so that's I mean it's obviously not
ideal but yeah we want first class
support for floating Point data that's
definitely on the
on the road map as well
how's that
Tate
um that was just from oh the weather
data you pulled that was just from I'm
really just getting questions from
hipchat and asking Tim
um so I'm kind of like a better sounding
automated voice
um I hope and uh is that just from the
gsod stuff that's on Noah's website yeah
so the all the data I pulled off is is
uh US Government gsod data for weather
um but AWS actually has a whole bunch of
this data that is mountable they have a
whole bunch of you know big data sets
that are just mountable as a snapshot so
it's kind of easy to get otherwise
you're downloading like multi-gigabyte
you know tar files and stuff and
um so that's how we did it that's that's
one of the reasons we're on AWS with
this demo
are we good I think we're out of time
but I want to thank all you guys for for
uh sticking with it and um yeah download
it and check it out it's uh we're pretty
proud of it
I could be